christelle staus and keo matsepe have
called it quits
it's a little bit of a letdown e.t has
learned exclusively that after less than
three months since their relationship
became public
the couple has decided to split i
the pair originally met while the
selling sunset star competed on the 29th
season of dancing with the stars
she was partnered with pro gleb
cevchenko while keo's celebrity partner
was actress
anne heish hi baby
but it wasn't until this photo of keo
seemingly kissing the sight of
christelle's face was posted
that their romance was
there it revealed since announcing their
relationship to the public the couple
shared
multiple pda-filled moments all over
social media
the news of their breakup comes just
days after krischell's divorce from
justin hartley was finalized
chrishell and justin split in november
2019
after two years of marriage i found out
because he texted me
that we were filed he texts you
e.t has learned that while there were
never court appearances
the former couple had reached an
agreement and mediated the case in july
2020.
these things are painful and they're
real their marital status officially
changed february 8
2021 per court records the this is us
actor has since moved on and is
currently dating his former the young
and the restless co-star
sophia pernice last year crochetl opened
up to et about the idea of
dating again i feel like with the summer
you've had
and now going on dancing with the stars
people got to be sliding into your dms
i have to say i have had
a few yes it's been yeah i don't know
how to answer that it feels so weird but
yes that has been
a nice surprise oh anybody we might know
there's a few but i'm not going to tell
you who
okay but but right now you're single and
ready to keep mingling
completely single and because of covet i
haven't done much mingling i'm excited
to mingle
you